transition is not easy in order for you
to go from one level to the next level
in order for any woman to transition for
any man to transition the thing that
they want must be greater than the thing
they currently understand this the next
major step that you take in your life or
in your business will come by you
raising your standards and all this
kumbaya crap about just do it for
loveable the end of the day if you got
to keep the lights on right rise and
shine it since preso time what's up
believe nation at 7:00 my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent
adds something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message pay the fare
over to you Eric Thomas the transitions
going to be hard I'm not gonna lie to
you
go from being on the block going to be a
high school dropout to getting a GED is
not the transition is not easy in order
for you to go from one level to the next
level in order for any woman to
transition for any man to transition the
thing that they want must be greater
than the thing they currently asked you
only go to another level when you roll
when you own this level and you eat not
a trash cans and you say enough is
enough
when you live in an abandoned buildings
in the winter and you say enough you
only transition from one level to the
next when you tie to the level you own
you keep telling me just happened in
your life and that's happening in your
life and it who is happening to
everybody
you let your pain Punk you you let your
pain make you quit you think you special
you think you don't only want we all go
through I'm just gonna give somehow
tomorrow so you gonna have to go through
it just like everybody else you gonna
have to pay the fair sweat blood here
but guess what when you walk across that
stage and don't have that much more
meaningful to me this is just about
raising your standards every single
major breakthrough that you make in your
life and your business will
come from you just understanding a
certain strategy better
it's from raising your standards it's
saying where I am now is not where I am
going to be I no longer accept this
situation my living condition the size
of my business is not acceptable anymore
people bombard and you people picking on
you people being a hater towards you
negative people in your life I no longer
accept how people cheat me this is not
acceptable anymore needs to change like
it doesn't matter about the specific
strategies it starts in here it's the
mindset it's raising your standards it's
feeling like you deserve more it's
knowing that you deserve more that you
are capable of great things and you are
going to go off and do it believing in
yourself that you can accomplish this
big thing and not accepting mediocrity
anymore that's a starting point and okay
and then so great raise my standards
awesome pay the fare awesome how do I do
it Evan how do I get it to happen to me
the greatest way to do it is to be
around the people who have the standards
that you want you are a product of your
environment if you're around people who
have bad standards low standards low
self-esteem low self-worth and guess
what you get for yourself you'll get the
same thing you need to be around the
people who have the standards that you
aspire to and the more that you are
hanging around those people the more
it's gonna rub off on you this is why I
do my channel and this is why I'm so
proud of the new free course that I
launched confidence 254 ideally this is
an entire series but the idea behind it
is if you want to improve your
confidence the best way to do it is to
be around people who are confident and
so every morning for free you get a clip
30 seconds the five minutes long around
people who are being confident all you
have to do is watch it don't don't be on
your phone don't be doing something else
just watch a clip for 30 seconds to 5
minutes every morning if you do that you
will become more confident why to 54
because it takes up to two hundred and
fifty four days for a new habit to sink
in and so I'm gonna be with you every
step of the way I'm giving you no excuse
no way out you want to be confident here
it is
gift wrap for you watch this every
single morning for free and the ultimate
goal of the
for me later to do 250 fors around
everything 250 fors around limited
beliefs 250 pours around self-love 250
fors for industries for filmmakers for
writers for athletes it's a lot of
resources to make that happen but this
is the starting point 250 for confidence
watch it every morning
and one of the gaps with entrepreneurs
is that they feel like because they own
their day they can spend it like they
won't you cannot spend it like you want
to if you gonna get to the next level
you're gonna have to give up something
right so that's my solution if you can't
actually be around these people then be
around them virtually consume their
content listen to them digest them try
to understand their mindset they will
rub off on you
but if you're spending your time
watching Netflix hanging around loser
friends hang on people who are
complaining and hating and saying no the
world sucks that will rub off on YouTube
so whether you sign up for a 2:54 for
free whether you watch more videos in
this channel whether you read books
whatever the thing is that helps you get
to where you need to go understand this
the next major step that you take in
your life or in your business will come
by you raising your standards by no
longer except in the status quo that
where you are right now and the way you
act behave and think is unacceptable for
the person that you want to be and that
needs to change
ASAP and to make that happen the best
way I know how is to create an
environment where on a daily basis you
are consuming and hanging around the
people who are already doing already
thinking already behaving in a way that
you aspire to be now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question the
day I'm curious what other 2:54 should
we launch so we've done the one on
confidence that's coming out we're now
looking at how do we branch out whether
it's other belief systems like self-love
like believe in yourself that kind of
stuff or if we go specific to an
industry like singers actors writers
down the line that path let me know you
think I'm curious to get your feedback
please leave it in the comments thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
a vinspresso and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
you know a lot of people don't ask
themselves why yeah do I want more cars
more jets and select no I don't I
speaking of mr. Cuban
uh I go to Dallas one day and I'm you
know I'm like man mark I never I never
been to your office man
tell me about it's the man's all kind of
thing it was huge probably right and
because and he's like alright I'll meet
you and then he comes to the hotel in
his pajamas and this is when sidekicks
without looking at his sidekick and I
said ok why am i good I mean I said I
wanna go your office he said I haven't
been in three years I said what do mean
you haven't been the office in three
years he said what am i what do I want
more money he said I want his chill home
when my son to jakester I want to answer
my things here I but I'm like but well
why do you publicly give out your email
if you don't want more work he's like I
enjoy sitting at home in my pajamas
looking at this stuff and I you know and
I realize you know he's just like me why
are you doing things you have to ask
yourself right and that is your
discipline right why am I going to work
every single day and of course I
understand a lot of people here don't
have the luxury like I am afforded now
and you have to go to work you have to
you have to keep the lights on and all
this kumbaya crap about just do it for
love the end of the day if you got to
keep the lights on right there's a crack
but but but uh
you got to ask yourself why what power
have you found in the darkness
first I before I answer that question I
want to say about listen to this I'm the
happiest man on the planet Earth so
people may take this and as so many
people do we live in a very weakened
society so when they hear a throwback
guy like me from back in the ancient
days of Garanimals they often think this
guy's just whatever so if you think that
I'm some unhappy guy you're wrong
having lived a life I've lived in seeing
the other side not being afraid to
attack what was in front of me has made
me happy say that again
and in fact let me make sure I
understood it getting to the point where
you're not afraid to face the thing on
the other side of the door that wants to
attack you has made you happy
right it's really powerful I hope people
heard that right that made me very happy
so basically I just don't walk around
with a dad gonna smile my face all the
time so you know Merry Christmas but but
basically what the dark side is is we
all have a cookie jar and we all have a
jar that's its official name it's a jar
of Man which just it's just ain't going
right and in hell week what they do in
hell week because this is where I really
went to the dark side we're doing hell
week because they designed hell week to
find your flaws and they do a really
good job of that it's a hundred thirty
hours of continuous training you may get
two hours of sleep and they beat you
will find everything wrong with your
mentality and then they start hell week
and that's the beauty of it and for me
I'm not some not no nasty guy giving guy
you know I don't have a great bit of
talent in anything so what got me
through horrible times was the dark side
whereas I created my name is David
Goggins I created Goggins Goggins is the
guy that can take anything you put in
front of them you want to break my legs
so be it
I have a way of going to a place like I
did in that race where all the pain and
suffering that they put on top of me in
hell week I will reverse that pain and
suffering and I will take your soul so
every instructor that put me through
buds my job what drove me was I wanted
you to go home that night after you beat
the living me and I smiled in your face
I wanted you to feel worse than I did
and you were going home to a nice warm
bed with your wife or your kids in a
nice meal and I was still out there in
the grip suffering for another 100 hours
I want you to think about me knowing
that I'm comfortable being very
comfortable and I
you think about when you went through
week how uncomfortable you weren't how
bad you wanted to quit knowing I'm not
thinking that way so the dark side is
something that I've designed it's an
evil place I can go that very few things
can hurt me I used to hurt you're trying
to put on me I flip it upside down and
use it you try to use it for kryptonite
know its power pillars for me I'm using
it for strength
I flipped negative into positive Saudis
now terrific world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video